справді ви знаєте в чому найбільший жах
і чому я розумію суспільство яке каже що
ее ну воно не довіряє українському
парламенту ста станом на зараз а
це вже не місце для дискусій якщо
впродовж української історії Це було
місце найбільших політичних дискусій і я
впевнена що це було на користь і на
розвиток країні Та то зараз обравши
монобільшість яка з моєї точки зору є от
великим злом яке Ми не маємо більше
допустити у власній політичній історії
та
люди побачили До чого це призводить до
можливості монополізації всього
монополізації кожного комітету до
монополізації фактично висвітлення цієї
роботи от некомфортно їм щоб ходили там
журналісти по другому поверху спочатку ж
до речі журналістів забрали з другого
поверху там де можна було просто підійти
до депутата і поставити запитання оце
було не камільфо